early it's lovely to see you here for
the premiere of they came together
tonight tell me a little bit about your
role in the film so I play a friend of
Amy and Paul along with my husband Bill
Hader and they are basically recounting
the trials and tribulations of their
love story together and it's a single
scene that is interspersed throughout
the movie and haven't seen it yet but um
you know the whole movie is a spoof of
the romantic comedy genre and it's I saw
an earlier cut which just is hilarious
and so silly and stupid and glorious so
I'm excited to see the new version how
much fun was it working with Amy bill
and Paul and also cause great director
and writing team Michael and David as
well I mean that's extraordinary we shot
it on a Sunday and I couldn't sleep
Saturday I was like I'm so excited
because it's just a what a fun day and
to be able to be involved with that in
any way it was really a plot it mean it
sounds so obvious to even say but it was
just a pleasure it was i again I'm a fan
of all of their work all of the people
involved and I just felt like okay just
make sure you carry the torch don't miss
anything go but it went it went well and
I had a ton of fun and what can we look
forward to from you next belly I get to
do a TV series about a woman who escapes
from a cult and starts life over in New
York City and it's written by Tina Fey
and Robert Carlock and it will air next
fall yeah so it's totally also how how
profound but it is it's totally awesome
what can we look forward to from your
character in that um you can look for a
young dare I say young woman I'm
starting over and just trying to find a
new beginning we haven't filmed anything
yet it's only on the page right now so
we'll do that soon and I'm just honored
and ecstatic to work with both of them
cannot wait to see that and loads of low
I'm sure we go brilliantly and I'm sure
everyone's looking forward to they came
together as well look I can't wait to
see it today thank you very much
you